Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody. Good to be
back. And so much to discuss. We'll start with
the situation in Russia, a failed coup attempt
which Vladimir Putin has survived. But to what
end and with what long term impact, we just don't
know. But let's go through what took place over
the weekend. Incredible. The Wagner Group. Wagner
group, everybody has their own way of pronouncing
it, launched a coup attempt by sending tanks and
troops towards the Russian capital of Moscow,
hoping to overthrow Vladimir Putin and put
in some kind of puppet leader. Quite frankly,
the mercenary group, the Wagner group, is led by
Yevgeny Prigozhin, formerly a close associate of
Vladimir Putin, sanctioned by the U.S., for
his role in interfering in the 2016 and 2020
elections. And Prigozhin alliance with Putin
soured when he accused Putin. Rather, he accused
the Russian defense minister of incompetence and
betrayal, claiming that he had ordered attacks
on Wagner's troops in Ukraine and elsewhere. The
timeline, as far as we understand it, is that on
Friday, June 23rd, Prigozhin threatened rebellion
Saturday, June 24th, very early, just hours later,
one in the morning on Saturday, Vladimir Putin
was briefed about the armed rebellion that was
being threatened. By 7:30 a.m., the Wagner group
claimed control over Rostov military facilities
and the airport. 2 hours later, the march towards
Moscow began. 10 a.m., Vladimir Putin addressed
Russia on television, calling the acts treasonous.
And by that night, 8 p.m. prigozhin as far as we
currently understood understand halted the march
on Moscow. The reports are that the coup attempt
was foiled by the bell of Russian President
Lukashenko brokering a deal between Putin
and Prigozhin, allowing Prigozhin to escape to
Belarus in exchange for some kind of safe haven.
Presumably Prigozhin has failed. Coup attempt also
has shown shifting public opinion about him and
the Wagner group and quite frankly, the ethical
dilemmas of supporting or opposing coups based on
who it is that is doing them. This is a critical
aspect to the story. Prigozhin coup attempt
had mixed reactions among both Russians and the
international community when news broke of this.
And in fact, I have some Ukrainian friends who,
with tears in their eyes, wrote out, wrote to me,
and I could tell even though they were texting,
that they had tears in their eyes. They were happy
about this. They welcomed it as a challenge to
Vladimir Putin's, of course, authoritarian rule
and the idea that maybe there could be
democratic change in Russia. Others condemned
the coup attempt, saying it's reckless, it's a
violent act, it threatens Russia's stability, it
threatens Tibetans, Russian security. Even if the
coup were to succeed, it's it does not set Russia
and the Russian people up for really dramatically
improved circumstances. There are those who say a
coup is never justified, regardless of the regime
that they are targeting, because coups undermine
the rule of law, they undermine the will of the
people. Others say, well, sometimes the rule of
law and the will of the people has been undermined
by the strongman who is in power already. And the
coup might be the only way to actually get back
on track. These are the various opinions that have
come forward. One position is that it's okay to
support coups if they are against undemocratically
elected leaders. Can it be said that Putin was
elected democratically? Well, he says he was.
There is this ostensible democracy, but was it?
Putin won his fourth presidential term with 77% of
the vote in an election that was widely criticized
by domestic and international observers for,
to put it lightly, irregularities and violations.
So is Putin actually democratically elected?
Putin's main opponents were either barred
from running or jailed, or even worse,
Putin's critics were excluded from the vote on
constitutional reforms, which allowed Putin to
reset term limits and run for two more six year
terms. That's not democracy. But does that mean we
support a coup attempt? And then, of course, the
the other part of this is that Prigozhin himself
initially seen by some favorably as someone
doing a good. Being worthy of the international
left's support. And that very quickly came apart
once more was learned about Prigozhin and Wagner
groups activities in different theaters around the
world. So that is where things stand right now,
as far as we know. There is not total transparency
about news regarding exactly what is going on,
but the broader and more forward looking question
to which I just don't think we have an answer. If
you Google what comes next in Russia, what happens
next to Putin? You will find several dozen op
eds from the last 24 to 48 hours know to agree
about what is coming next. And in particular,
for Vladimir Putin, the most optimistic sort of
blended scenario that I've seen proposals put
forth. Is that now with the threat of the
coup, but the coup having failed. Vladimir
Putin may realize his days are numbered and
will engineer some kind of face saving exit
from power to avoid being deposed or whatever.
I just don't know that that's really the most
likely scenario here. So that's the latest we
have out of Russia as of this moment. We're
going to continue following it. We'll probably
have more for you tomorrow or the next day